تقدر وزاره الماليه الروسيه حجم الاصول
المجمده من قبل الغرب بما يتراوح بين 300
مليار دولار
و350 مليارا اي قرابه نصف احتياطيات روسيا
من الذهب والنقد الاجنبي وسندات الدين
يملك البنك المركزي الروسي اكثر من 300
مليار دولار من الاموال المجمده قانونيا
تعود ملكيه هذه الاصول للدوله الروسيه
لكنها لا تستطيع التصرف بها بسبب العقوبات
وتقدر الاموال الخاصه بمواطنين يحملون
الجنسيه الروسيه بنحو 30 مليار دولار تصنف
هذه الاموال في فئه الملكيه الفرديه
الخاصه خبراء في القانون يؤكدون وجود
اختلاف جذري بين تجميد الاسود ومصادرتها
فالتجميد خطوه تحتمل ان تكون قانونيه اما
المصادره فتحتاج الى قوانين لحال خاصه لا
يمكن تعميمها ورغم جهود مشرعين امريكيين
لوضع قوانين تمكن الرئيس من استخدام
الاموال الروسيه المجمده الا ان القوانين
النافذه واضحه يمنح قانون السلطه الطوارئ
الاقتصاديه الدوليه رئيس الولايات المتحده
السلطه كي يشمد الاصول المملوكه لاجانب
بما في ذلك ممتلكات دول اجنبيه
والتجميد في هذه الحاله يهدف الى تدمير
القيمه الاقتصاديه للاصول بتجريم محاوله
التعامل بها او الحصول على منافع منها لكن
التجميد في هذه الحاله لا يعني تغيير
ملكيه تلك الاصول وبحسب خبراء هناك
استثناء نادر جدا في هذا القانون يمنح
الرئيس الحق في مصادره الممتلكات الاجنبيه
والتصرف بها
والاستثناء يكون بترقب او وقوع اعمال
عدائيه من قبل دوله اجنبيه
او مواطنين اجانب فما هي المشاكل
القانونيه التي تعوق المصادره
يميز خبراء القانون بين الاصول الخاصه
التي جمدتها حكومات غربيه وبين ممتلكات
الدوله مثل احتياطيات العملات الاجنبيه
للبنك المركزي الروسي في حاله الاصول
الخاصه تعني الضمانات القانونيه انه لا
يسمح للدول الغربيه بمصادرتها الا في حال
اثبات انها عائدات من انشطه اجراميه
وبالتالي فان مصادرتها تشكل تعديا على
الحقوق القانونيه وحقوق الانسان الاساسيه
لصعوبه اثبات الجرم اما الاصول العامه
للدول فعاده ما ترتبط باتفاقيات استثمار
ثنائيه او دوليه وبالتالي فان مصادرتها قد
تعرض الدول المعنيه لمطالبات قانونيه في
محاكم دوليه
من جهه اخرى تطرح اصول الدول كاحتياطيات
البنك المركزي مشاكل مختلفه لكنها شائكه
ايضا لانها مغطاه بما تسمى الحصانه
السياديه وهي تفاهم يقضي بان لا تستولي
دوله على ممتلكات دوله اخرى اما روسيا
فتبدو مستعده للرد في حال المصادره اذ وقع
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما يقضي بوضع
الاصول الاجنبيه في روسيا تحت السيطره
المؤقته للدوله او تحت ادارتها مؤقتا اذا
تمت مصادره اصول روسيه في الخارج
[موسيقى]